[Music]
what's going on everybody and welcome to
my patreon so just to give a little bit
of a background to why I'm starting this
patreon I think it's pretty obvious
right if you want to get to know who I
am and you want to know the type of
content that I make
just ask the fans of this page and
you'll know that it's a unapologetic
comedy [ __ ] kind of interesting so the
reason why I'm starting a patreon is
because because of who I am
YouTube as decide to de monetize about
like 70% of my videos son of a [ __ ] and
look I've been away from YouTube for a
while so I haven't really thought about
how much that ad pocalypse or the D
monetization of videos really started to
affect me in my channel how much money I
was losing this is where you guys come
in and obviously with my patreon this is
not me trying to mask it and say that no
this is something for you guys which you
know in terms of community and me being
able to really like [ __ ] with y'all this
is this is probably the way to go you
know and it and I'll be real man it kind
of feels weird starting a patreon but
through the advice of specific fans and
a lot of my friends they said that a
patreon might be the way to go and if
people are willing to support me that
support will be there so here we are in
the patreon you guys will get exclusive
content and I'll just be able to
interact and just really connect with
you guys from creative to fan
I have tried creating relationships with
people through like Facebook fan page
and just a whole bunch of other stuff
and then never seem to really work out
really well but I heard that patreon was
the place for us to really develop a
personal relationship and specifically
helped me to create better content I
want to go back to sketches I want to go
back to creating better content but that
requires money like even with the
podcast I would love to have three
cameras I love that better guest but I
need an office for that but welcome to
the patreon guys and yeah basically I
just don't see myself changing anytime
soon you have [ __ ] [ __ ] listen
you guys already know I'm not going to
censor myself it's just not going to
happen if it would have happened the
first three or four ad pocalypse as ago
I would have done it no I think comedy
should be unapologetic some people can
[ __ ] with it some people shouldn't and
if it's just based on the fact that I
crushed a lot and I have opinions well
suck it up [ __ ] I got to beat myself
just like I suggest you
to always be yourself and if YouTube can
monetize off of somebody else filming
somebody hanging off a [ __ ] tree I
think that uh I think my videos are fine
yeah
but anyways thank you guys for
supporting me if you are donating to the
patreon thank you very much and if
you're not still love you anyways man
but for those of you who can help
appreciate you a lot I love you very
much and I'm gonna name my firstborn
after you it's gonna be a really really
really long person